- Hi, everyone. Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the EDTalks,
version of our Homeroom
with Sal live stream.
We have a very exciting conversation today
with LaVerne Srinivasan.
But before we get into that conversation,
I will give my standard reminders.
First of all, we are not in for profit.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate.
Donations of all sizes
make a huge difference
and allow us to deliver Khan Academy
to hundreds of millions of
people around the world.
I also wanna make a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up,
especially during the
pandemic when they realized
that more people than ever
we're leaning on Khan Academy,
which also meant our costs were going up.
Our server costs and
our desire to accelerate
a whole bunch of programs.
So special thanks to Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly and general motors.
And then last but not least,
there is a podcast version
of this live stream available
wherever you get your podcasts
on "Homeroom with Sal the podcast".
So definitely check that out.
So with that, I am excited to
introduce LaVerne Srinivasan,
who is Vice President
and Director of Education
at the Carnegie Corporation.
Full disclosure, also a
funder of Khan Academy.
So I am somewhat biased, but
LaVerne, great to see you.
Thanks for joining us.
- Great to see you too,
Sal. Pleasure to be here.
- Well, maybe a good place to start
for those who haven't heard,
and I'm sure there aren't many,
what does the Carnegie
Corporation of New York do?
And what does the director of education do
within that context?
- Absolutely. Carnegie
Corporation of New York
is actually a foundation that has invested
in knowledge to inspire
informed actions since 1911.
We actually invest in
democracy, international peace
and security and in education.
And for my role in the education
program, we are focused
on ensuring that our American
public education system serves
all students by building
the knowledge, skills
and dispositions that they
need to be active participants
in our democracy and be able to thrive
and engage fully in our economy.
So we have five grant making portfolios,
but our strategy is really
focused on making sure
that parents and educators
can be full partners
in transforming the learning experience.
You think it's absolutely critical
that our best hope for having equitable
and transformed learning
environment is by fully engaging
the adults and building their capacity
and also ensuring that
they can work in a system
that's optimized to ensure
their effectiveness,
including making sure that
their actions are informed
by knowledge that's been
developed in the field.
So our five portfolios are,
new design students learning,
where we focus on innovations
in classrooms and schools
to promote a better student
learning ,and youth development.
We also focus on pathways
to post-secondary success
where we re-imagined pathways
for high school graduates
including access and completion of college
and better aligning
K-12 higher and careers.
We have another portfolio focused
on leadership and teaching
to advanced learning, where we focus
on high quality curriculum
and strengthening teaching
and learning to implement
that high quality standards
aligned, that curriculum,
along with professional learning.
We also have a portfolio that
focuses on family engagement.
It's a public understanding portfolio,
where we're really looking to
have a shared understanding
of how all of the adults in
the system can work together
along with students to transform
the learning environment.
And lastly, we have an
integration learning
and innovation portfolio.
And in that portfolios where
we really inspire all folks
who are essential in transforming
our nation's education
system to develop strategies
and implement them in complex systems.
And share the learning associated
with that and foster collaboration.
So those are our five portfolios though.
- And that was super helpful.
And I just wanna remind everyone watching,
especially those who are watching live,
if you have any questions
for Laverne or myself,
we wanna get to them.
So please put them in the message board
under wherever you're watching this,
Facebook, YouTube, wherever.
But LaVerne, on this focus on education,
I'm curious about where
you are most excited,
where you're most hopeful and especially,
has the last year changed
your perspective on anything
given all of the disruption
that has happened
to education because of the pandemic?
- Yeah, so I feel we've really
reflected on this deeply
because there has been so much disruption
and there are so many people
who are really struggling
and have struggled, and also people
who have had incredible experiences.
But within our work we realize
that so many of the aspects
of the focus in our five
portfolios are turning out
to be really important
aspects of places, schools,
school systems that have
been able to pivot and adjust
and adapt effectively in
this disruptive environment.
So in particular, I'd say
one of our newer portfolios
although we've been
invested now for six years
in family engagement,
that's been a real area
of priority for us, and
one that has been essential
in helping through our grantees
respond to the challenges
that families have faced with the tsunami
of resources coming at them to the extent
that they have them, but
also really connecting
with their teachers, their
schools and school environments
and our grantees have really,
I think stepped up incredibly
well to help all parents
and schools, teachers
and educators connect
with families in more meaningful ways.
So we're excited about the possibilities
that this has in continuing to
build commitment and to build
on the strength of what's
happened over the last year,
so that we'd no longer operate in a way
that has some artificial
constraints and walls
around schools that don't effectively,
in the past did not effectively
engage parents as well,
and communities as well
as they could have.
- And we have two
questions that double click
on what you just talked about.
Both questions from YouTube,
Susanna Garcia Dominguez,
who's a regular on the show, so to speak.
I almost view her as a co-host of sorts.
But I've never met her in-person,
but I look forward to one day.
She says, hi LaVerne, please share some
of the most innovative
projects you support.
Thanks for all you do from YouTube
Suehib Alashkar also saying, what are some
of the projects you
support and in what way?
So especially with this parent engagement,
why do you think there
was a gap to begin with?
And what are some of the efforts
that you all are supporting
that you think it could close this gap?
Because it does seem in some ways obvious
that like the parent is an
incredibly important actor
for children's learning.
- Yeah, I think we historically
focused in school systems
on parent engagement is just an activity
where we were inviting parents
to come at the very least
for parent-teacher conferences,
maybe for bake sales
and other activities.
But there hasn't always been, and this is,
you can't paint the entire country
with one broad brush stroke around this.
But you know, I think
that a lot of efforts
were involving bringing parents
into the school environment
to participate in some
particularly focused way.
And I think the difference
in what we have seen
in the last year, and by
the way, research has not,
we know through research
for quite some time
that parent engagement is essential
to improving student outcomes.
So what we've seen is
for example, you know,
efforts that we supported,
that homeschool connection.
Engagement isn't just about you know,
showing up in schools on school time.
Parents have busy schedules,
not every parent can come
in at the prescribed times
that schools invite them in.
So how do we create an environment
where there is a more dynamic engagement
between home and school?
One of our grantees that is really strong
in this area is PowerMyLearning,
where they've created
an innovative app, that
allows children to demonstrate
what they're learning
in school by actually,
basically teaching it
to a caregiver or parent
or other adult in their homes,
outside of the school environment.
So it really triangulates
in a way that home, school,
teacher, parent and student
learning and creates a more,
you know, bi-directional
engagement that fosters
a more inclusive learning environment.
So those are the kinds
of things we can do.
I mean, during the pandemic,
there were also, you know,
efforts that helped with
translation, you know,
or how parents understand how
to read to their children,
like springboard collaborative.
So there are, it's a matter of fact
we actually have a number of
these resources on our website
that we tried to help
curate for busy families
who also couldn't work through
the tsunami of resources
and started flowing their way.
So I think the real secret,
Sal, and what I hope
we will see looking
different going forward,
is a better understanding
of where families are,
and meeting them where they
are in a more authentic way
as opposed to just let us
invite you into our four walls.
- Now I love that example you gave.
You know, I've always been a
huge advocate and supporter
that some students could
actually be incredible teachers
at least tutors, maybe I should say.
And to maybe leverage
them within a classroom
to tutor each other or
to tutor younger peers.
But it sounds like y'all
are taking it further
with some of your grantees to say,
well, why can't the students
tutor their parents?
Which I think is a very,
very, very powerful idea,
because it is.
You know, I always cringe when a parent,
but I understand at the
same time when they say,
Oh, well, I haven't seen
this since fourth grade.
I was like, yeah, you went to
fifth grade and sixth grade.
But there is sometimes this
fear of parents to even engage,
but this almost, this
kind of flips the things
in a really interesting way.
What are your...
You know, you've been in
the field of philanthropy,
in the field of education for a while.
And you know, I like
you, I'm very optimistic
about where the world can go,
but there's also sometimes
cynicism that people
have been working on
this problem for a while.
They've been throwing
money at different parts
of the problem, but at least
from some vantage points
it looks like it hasn't moved the dial.
Do you agree with some of that cynicism?
Do you have some fears?
And how the philanthropic world do y'all,
maybe even learn from some of, you know,
it might not be things y'all have done,
but it's stuff that had
happened in the past
and what are those learnings?
- Yeah, that's a great question, Sal.
You're right, I want to be optimistic,
but I also wanna be realistic.
And we really have a big
challenge in front of us.
I found myself thinking about,
we have to get out of our comfort zones.
We all have to grapple with new ideas
and engage ineffectively
a design challenge
where instead of gravitating
to just siloed solutions
that we really start to
look at the full ecosystem
of learning, and the in-center
children and families
in that as authentic partners
in it and designers in it.
But also to recognize that, you know,
we can't all in the education
sector, you know, get attached
to the thing that we think
is the most effective
or likely to be the most
highly effective solution
to addressing the change we
need to see in education,
or to better meet student learning needs.
So I think one of the
things we have to learn
is less fragmentation, more collaboration,
much better sharing of
learning, understanding
that it's not just what we do that matters
but how we do it that matters.
Those I think are going to
be essential in making change
and you know, aligning resources,
aligning that highly effective curriculum
with aligned professional learning.
Keeping and considering that
adults and students make up
that learning environment
that we really need
to transform to really lean into a future
that is gonna thrive on lifelong learning.
And so if our learning environments
aren't more porous inside of
school, outside of school,
at home, learning happens
in all of those environments
and how we really take ourselves
out of our comfort zone
to really think and imagine a
way that we can knit together
the positive and promising
proof points and solutions
that we've seen to actually
support adults and students
to thrive in a transformed
and more equitable
learning environment and
a learning ecosystem.
- Yeah, it sounds like one of
the key takeaways has been,
it's not just what happens...
Obviously what happens in the classroom
is incredibly important,
but what goes on beyond
the classroom, especially the family.
And you know, related to
that, the pandemic introduced
a lot of disruption, but
people explored things
like pod schooling and
homeschooling and distance learning.
And for a lot of folks that
didn't work, but for some
it seems like at least parts of it might.
And related to that, there's
a question from YouTube.
Strava Padwell asks, "Hey,
LaVerne what do you think
about homeschool learning
and normal school?"
And I'll just add to that.
Do you think we're we're kind
of gonna start hybridizing
in certain ways, you know,
that's kind of the
ultimate bringing the home
into the classroom?
- Yeah, I think that,
I think that what happened
with pods is really,
really compelling.
In many ways, you know, I
think people are focused
on the fact that there were pods,
but what did pods represent?
I mean, pods represented
another opportunity
to bring community and families together.
Again, understanding
better what's necessary
to support their students
and their children
and their learning and a
little bit more of a strategy
around how you can focus
that in smaller groups.
Well, we can learn from
that both in the classroom,
but we can also learn that, not
everyone learns the same way
Paying attention to the individual
needs of students allows
you all of a sudden to
open your mind and realize
that learning in classrooms
can be approached differently.
And we do it now, that it
happens in small pods in schools
with attention from
one teacher and ability
to accelerate learning while
others are finishing learning
hat they're not as fully advanced in yet.
So I think that, you know,
I think homeschooling
is something that works
extraordinarily well
for some families.
And I think families know
best what's gonna work
for their kids.
But I think again, that
making it more porous,
realizing that there's
something that we can all learn
by centering the needs
of students and the needs
that specific students
have for their learning
and to advance not only
their academic development
but their socio-emotional
development as well,
I think are what's gonna
make the difference
in whether we learn from
this experience and advance
our conception of what learning
is and where it takes place,
or whether we stay rooted
in a compliance oriented
industrial age education system.
- Makes a lot of sense.
And there's another question here.
I guess it's a question for both of us.
From Facebook Mila Nalani Prabhu says,
"Hi, Sal and LaVerne,
please list down in order
what I as a parent tutor
can do for student success."
So I'll let you take a stab
at it. I have some ideas too
- As a student tutor.
Well, I guess it depends on
what they're tutoring in.
I think that it's important.
The parent or the tutor?
She said she is a parent.
What can I do like right
now to help my kids?
- Exactly. Okay.
I think there's some really
great resources out there.
I think Sal is probably gonna give us some
of those also from his perspective.
That wide open school, which
is actually one of our grantees
has some incredible resources
that were curated there
for parents and activities.
And depending on the
level your child is at,
you will find what, you
know, different resources
that will help you understand
what should my child know
at this level and what
activities or other strategies
can I use to make sure
that I help them at home,
continue to advance and
learn along the pathway
that they're on.
In addition, there are
also other resources
whether it's a great schools.
Again, I invite you to go
to our website as well,
not as a commercial for our website,
but to say we've tried to
thoughtfully curate some
of these things that we think
will help parents navigate.
And if you're having young children,
reading is so essential.
Having the opportunity to
read with your child is one
of the most critical things
that you can certainly do.
Sal.
- Yeah, I love all of
those and I will add things
that will not surprise anyone.
But you know, Khan Academy
as I tell everybody
who will listen, if you're able
to work with their children
I don't know how old they are,
but we go down all the way
to Khan Academy kids all the way through,
especially Khan Academy kids
covers math, reading, writing,
social emotional learning,
but then, you know,
math we are very comprehensive all the way
through middle high school,
college level mathematics.
And they're pretty consistent.
And you know, we have 50 efficacy studies
that have students even
put in 45 minutes a week.
It grows them 20, 30 in some
cases, 50% more than expected.
So if your child is able to put in,
I would say 15 minutes a
day, which is very doable,
you know, and you can help
motivate them as a parent.
In two or three months I will be surprised
if you don't see a massive difference.
Otherwise I will give a
personal money back guarantee.
Partially joking.
But even if we did charge you,
I would stand behind that
with a money back guarantee.
And the other is effort-
- I can vouch as a parent.
- Go ahead.
- As a parent I've
actually used Khan Academy
with my child as well.
- Oh, no, I actually, we've
talked about that before.
And I actually that I
think is our most powerful.
You know, even when we
talked to philanthropists,
if the philanthropy sees
that works for their family,
they're like, Hey it could
work for a lot of folks family.
But the other effort is
as an effort which is,
that you could do this as
a spin off of Khan Academy
or complimentary effort
called schoolhouse.world
for free tutoring.
So if your child is 13 or over,
they can either get free tutoring .
Right now it's math and SAT,
but it's going to expand.
And actually it's
expanded into the sciences
and AP subjects as well.
But also if once they
really master concepts,
they can give tutoring to
other people is analogous
to what LaVerne was
saying about the power.
When you teach others not
only are you helping them,
but you're helping yourself.
So there's a lot of resources now
and it's just about making sense of them
and doing them consistently.
You know, it's all about
we're all guilty of like,
I'm gonna play a guitar and
I'm gonna do 10 hours today,
and then it drifts away.
But it's all about if you
do 15, 20 minutes a day
for a long period of time
it makes a huge difference.
So LaVerne and these
conversations always go faster
than I expect, but I also wanna you know,
kind of understand a little
bit of your background.
What got you into this field?
How did you get into philanthropy,
education in particular?
How did you get here?
- Sure, well, I was
fortunate enough to grow up
in a family that absolutely
thought education
was the most important thing.
And I'm so grateful every day for that.
And that has had me on a lifelong journey,
whether it was tutoring
younger kids or working
while I was in college
to set up opportunities
in communities to work with
young people, with computers
and helping them do exactly
what we're talking about now,
which is sort of out of school
learning, that's something,
or being a mentor.
That those are all things that I did,
while I wasn't in education as a career.
But what inspired me
to get into education,
stay in education is
actually using my skills
and background from private
sector experience that I had,
and to think about how
to transform the system.
And transforming a complex
system like education
is really hard to do,
but it gets a little bit more realistic
to believe it can be done,
which is what I've seen
when you actually center
students and families
and communities, and you
design from that perspective.
You really have to stretch
ourselves to get out
of our compliance-oriented
approach to education,
because that's not the
expansive learning environment
and ecosystem we need to succeed.
So that my family inspired me.
My teachers inspired me.
Those who brought everything
to life in the classroom,
whether it was in an English
class or a science class
all of that has led me to say
I want everyone to have
the opportunity that I feel
like I was fortunate enough to have.
- And on that last point as we ramp
into teacher appreciation
week, I'm curious,
are there any teachers that you...
I'm sure many teachers
that you wanna appreciate,
but any that come to mind that, you know,
you really made a lasting impact on you?
- Yeah, I will say, I wanna
appreciate all teachers
just because one of the
things that I've done
in education is really focused
on how important teachers are.
So first shout out to all
teachers, you are all special.
And I hope in this time
of COVID, when everyone
has had to get so much
closer to understanding
what teaching is all about and
what it means for their kids,
that we all appreciate all of you more.
In particular I'll shout out Ronny Clemmer
and Beverly Hannah.
They were both English teachers of mine.
One in middle school
and one in high school.
And they just brought
every book to life for me,
made it relevant, made it
engaging, and really contributed
to sort of my lifelong love of reading.
- Now that's great.
I mean, I think the, you know,
the teachers in our lives
that have made a difference.
Yeah, I mean, it just keeps going
and unfortunately they don't
hear probably about it enough,
'cause, you know, maybe when
you were in middle school
or high school, we're
not always there to say,
Hey teacher you've changed my life,
but then when we're in our 30s
and 40s and 50s, we're like,
Wow, it'd be incredible to tell them that.
Well, LaVerne, thank you so much
for being part of this conversation.
I hope it's the first of many.
And I look forward to our
partnership, our journey,
doing all of the things that
we talked about and more.
And as we said is, you know,
there's sometimes people
get cynical about education,
but I've never been more optimistic.
So thank you so much.
- Well, it is such a
pleasure to be on the show
and to work with you, Sal.
So thank you for having me,
- Well, thanks everyone for joining,
especially it's been a little while
since we did one of
these. I was on vacation.
I went to Joshua Tree, very,
very nice, highly recommend it.
Actually, I'm gonna post a video
on it on my new TikTok account.
I was very dismissive of
TikTok until I tried it out.
And now I'm kind of, I think getting it.
But thanks for joining.
And I look forward to seeing y'all shortly
for our next Homeroom live stream,
which I think will be next week,
but I will see you all then.
(upbeat music)